bonsoir louis sa famille merci d'être
avec nous en direct lomé au togo
quatre mois après donc la présidentielle
houleuse on s'en souvient la situation
s'est elle véritablement apaisées en
côte d'ivoire pour l'instant en réjouir
chacune des formations politiques et
c'est d'accuser le climat dans lequel
cette élection va se dérouler et c'est
tant mieux parce que cela fait
aujourd'hui plusieurs décennies que la
côte d'ivoire est plongée dans la
violence
il faut se souvenir que les premières
violences liées à la démocratie en côte
d'ivoire ont proposé le président
laurent gbagbo qui est aujourd'hui à la
et qui a en belgique après avoir été
transféré à l'oeil à leur art au
président actuel le président alassane
dramane ouattara qui lui présente la
côte d'ivoire qui à l'époque le premier
ministre deux du président houphouët
boigny dont on est là d'argent moments
de la vie politique de la côte d'ivoire
qui est comme un grand changement parce
que la plupart de ces actes quand là ne
sont pas des états ne sont pas au
premier plan comme on aurait pu le
penser
le président va faire en sorte d'une
élection présidentielle qui la galette
et même sur laquelle sa légitimité reste
encore très contesté le premier ministre
ahmed bakayoko qui aurait pu porter les
couleurs du parti est en france depuis
plus de deux semaines pour des raisons
médicales
le président gbagbo même s'il est très
présent sa formation politique
aujourd'hui est revenu sur le sur la
scène et a arrêté la série de boycott
qui a su son arrestation et son
transfèrement a fait alliance avec le
pdc y prônait une vraie reconfiguration
mais le problème c'est qu'on a
l'impression que les têtes qui devait
porter cette nouvelle scène politique
pour marquer la praye affrontements des
amis les trente ans que c'est je laisse
la seconde nouvellement non pour la
première fois depuis dix ans les ai
presque tous les partis d'opposition
sont sont représentées c'est un signe de
démocratie on peut dire ça comme ça je
pense que ces deux premiers pas vers la
réconciliation
sur le président aura énormément pêcher
sur le terrain de la réconciliation lors
de ses deux premiers mandats
cette fois ci il a créé un ministère
dédié à cette cause là et il est
probablement intéressant de noter que
même s'il n'y a pas de liaison de cause
à effet entre la création de ce
ministère et l'ambiance qui a autour des
élections des six têtes tout actuelle il
est ce lui qui n'est pas de violence qui
canalise l'âme élections les
législatives qui sont à venir
alors laurent gbagbo on vous en parlait
tout à l'heure il annoncé dans un
message à ses partisans qu'il rentrera
bientôt en côte d'ivoire on imagine que
c'est pas anodin quelques jours avant
ces législatives
non ce n'est pas anodin parce que cela
permet de galvaniser les troupes cela
permet de resserrer les liens autour de
ce parti car un mot souffert d'abord
souffert du fait qu'il n'y avait plus de
chiens et du parti et à ses branches de
ce qu'on appelait le bal kubiak
il reconnaissait aucun des sept épis
choisi dans pastel a filé sans qui le
dernier chef par lequel la scission est
venu au sein du fbi et qui aujourd'hui
n'ont souhaité qu'ils pensent que le
veut le lieu secret où le plus clair de
paix dans ma peau c'est que sa famille
politique se reconstitue au dos d'un
seul blu et non plus au bout de plus de
deux ou trois blocs comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui
afin de vous présenter cette fort parce
qu'il ya un gars qui a permis à la côte
d'ivoire d'accéder à la démocratie et
qui a aussi élevé pendant une dizaine
d'années avant d'être renversé dans les
années 2000 alors parti de gbagbo qui
s'est allié en rappel avec celui de l'ex
président auront quand bédié on peut
parler
oui d'alliance inédite oui parce que
c'est l'alliance qui l'a fait tomber et
un communiqué cette année ans de
haricots embêter avec alassane dramane
ouattara qui a permis que le
renversement de voix profite au second
tour alassane ouattara et non pas à leur
encontre
donc légitimement on pourrait considérer
que c'est une alliance contre nature
mais le sort politique et la plupart du
temps les liaisons ne sont pas toujours
des liaisons très logique c'est le cas
aujourd'hui notamment en côte d'ivoire y
avait déjà eu une alliance entre laurent
gbagbo et alassane dramane ouattara
si à l'époque où le président avait été
considéré comme non signé et qu'à part
de enfin interdit de se présenter à la
présidentielle est revenu en trombe
républicain qui a été constitué avec
laurent gbagbo
aujourd'hui le mieux le bien un portique
et avec le président henri konan côté
son les messieurs les annales du type
d'alliance ou la scène politique
ivoirienne
ils sont réellement depot center à des
cultes et merci à louis comme aller au
président du club de l'information
africaine